hello i i i worked for
i actually worked for um a guy who was a
king in africa
and he had eight wives
and all the wives they just they just
they knew
i think men
say personally i think women are made
for more polyamorous relationships than
men
and then why do we have to go on birth
control to do it
if we're made for it but i think what do
you mean
like to have a polyamorous relationship
like you have to go on birth control
wait that's that's why there's condoms
as well i know what i'm saying like if
it's natural to us so then why don't men
just have birth control
because men naturally want to spread
their seed
so like thank you bro yeah
thank you that's why i'm saying it's
literally it's literally not natural to
us because like
the reason we want it like everyone
wants to have sex is because like
there's biological reasoning like we
want to reproduce so women we want to
reproduce with the highest like value
guy we can
where
where
men just want kids left and right like
biologically but like you know
guys don't don't be having like five
baby mamas that's trash no don't do that